2018's blockbuster season is officially underway.
The months ahead will see the release of plenty
of high profile titles, including Deadpool
2, Jurassic World: Fallen Kingdom, and Solo:
A Star Wars Story, and that's just the beginning.
In fact, just about every major upcoming film
dropped a new trailer over the past month.
It's a lot to take in if you're not paying
attention.
In case you missed them, here's a look at
all the new trailers from April 2018 that
are sure to blow you away.
The Cleanse
Not to be confused with the movie The Purge,
The Cleanse sees a group of people heading
out to a mountain health retreat to partake
in a purging ritual to cleanse the toxins
from their body.
But one guy purges something a little more
sinister than bad feelings: He lets out an
actual demon.
The Cleanse premiered at South by Southwest
in 2016 under the title The Master Cleanse,
then sat quietly for two years waiting for
a distribution deal.
With a brand new trailer preceding the film's
upcoming release, mainstream audiences finally
got a glimpse of the quirky horror comedy.
Look for The Cleanse in theaters and on video-on-demand
on May 4th.
The 12th Man
This upcoming film tells the true story of
a Norwegian freedom fighter who goes on the
run after his group of saboteurs is captured
and executed by the Nazis.
Equal parts harrowing survival thriller and
action-packed war drama, The 12th Man is bound
to be a tense, unforgettable experience.
While the film premiered in Norway in December
2017, distributor IFC Midnight has it slated
for a May 4th release in the U.S.
Anon
From writer/director Andrew Niccol, Anon takes
place in the near future where surveillance
technology ensures that nothing happens without
a record.
Everything a person sees is recorded and archived.
Anonymity is a thing of the past, and no crime
goes unpunished.
But when Detective Sal Freiland played by
Clive Owen, encounters a mysterious woman
who can erase all records of her existence,
he finds himself plunged into a world of paranoia
where nothing is what it seems.
Look for Anon on Netflix on May 4th.
Deadpool 2
Fox was more than happy to let the fan speculation
about the new mutants in Deadpool 2 run wild
for months, but their final trailer finally
names a few of the newcomers, like Bedlam
and Shatterstar.
Oh, and Peter, who just wants to hang out.
"Um, I just saw the ad."
"You're in."
What else is there to see in the newest Deadpool
2 trailer?
A whole lot of action and plenty of jokes,
of course.
"So dark.
You sure you're not from the DC universe?"
Deadpool 2 lands in theaters on May 18th.
Cargo
Starring Martin Freeman, Cargo tells the story
of a father in rural Australia who finds himself
stranded in the middle of a zombie outbreak.
To make matters worse, he's stuck with the
most precious cargo of all, his infant daughter.
Based on a short film that made waves at Tropfest
Australia in 2013, Cargo sees the original
short's directors behind the camera for the
feature-length adaptation.
With a brand new trailer released in April,
Netflix offers a glimpse of the desolate world
of Cargo and promises an emotionally charged
journey with the ultimate stakes.
Look for it on May 18th.
Solo: A Star Wars Story
In a world where expensive blockbusters always
seem to want to bet on a sure thing, a Han
Solo origin story was all but inevitable.
The new trailer for Solo: A Star Wars story
sees Alden Ehrenreich's young Han taking on
what looks like his first smuggling job.
He's joined by Chewbacca, and for once, maybe
even the last time in his life, he has a good
feeling about things.
Unfortunately, most fans aren't feeling so
good about it.
Between a change of directors at the last
minute and reports of Disney bringing in an
acting coach for Ehrenreich, things haven't
boded well for this new incarnation of the
scruffy nerf-herder.
We'll all have to see what happens in this
galaxy far, far, away on May 25th.
Future World
Bizarre.
Strange.
Inexplicable.
There are many words to describe the trailer
for Future World, but they all basically mean
the same thing.
James Franco stars as a weird post-apocalyptic
warlord, with Suki Waterhouse as a weird robot,
Milla Jovovich as a weirder version of Resident
Evil's Alice, and Snoop Dogg as, well...he's
pretty normal, all things considered.
"You say that like that's a bad thing or something,
man."
The trailer is full of this stuff, and more.
Future World probably won't win any awards,
but it looks like a fun ride for anyone craving
some sci-fi action.
Look for Future World to drop on video-on-demand
on May 25th.
Upgrade
Upcoming action extravaganza Upgrade stars
Logan Marshall-Green as a regular ol' guy
who gets a neural implant that turns him into
a human weapon.
Is it the easiest writing trick in the world
to give your protagonist super fighting skills?
You bet, but from the looks of the trailer,
Upgrade will have more than enough style to
pull it off.
Whether any of that translates into a good
movie remains to be seen, but we'll be able
to find out when Upgrade hits theaters on
June 1st.
American Animals
Evan Peters headlines American Animals as
the real-life Warren Lipka, a college student
who orchestrated a bizarre heist to steal
a collection of rare books from the library
at Kentucky's Transylvania University.
Together with three friends, Lipka carried
out a meticulous plan to infiltrate the Rare
Book Room, subdue its one guard, a 50-year-old
librarian, and get rich by making off with
millions of dollars' worth of first editions.
"Can I just say how dumb this entire thing
is?"
The trailer promises a college-bound heist
movie equal parts Ocean's Eleven and Harold
& Kumar.
Check it out on June 1st.
Ocean's 8
While George Clooney's Danny Ocean was the
central driving force behind the first three
Oceans movies, it's his sister, Debbie Ocean,
who's putting together a team for Ocean's
8.
The heist: Steal a priceless diamond necklace
from the New York Met Gala.
The plan: super convoluted, as usual.
Sandra Bullock leads an all-star cast, and
Steven Soderbergh, who directed the first
three films, serves as a producer.
Look for all the high-stakes heist action
when Ocean's 8 lands in theaters on June 8th.
Hereditary
The first trailer for A24's Hereditary promised
a visually unique horror tale centered around
an unsettling young girl named Charlie.
In the second trailer, Charlie's inner demons
crawl into the light just a little bit more.
It still doesn't explain much about the story,
but it doesn't need to.
The trailer is a whirlwind of activity, and
if the movie is even half as creepy as these
trailers have been, it's bound to become one
of the best horror films of 2018.
You can find out when it hits theaters on
June 8th.
Hotel Artemis
The April trailer for Hotel Artemis dropped
out of a clear blue sky, but was quick to
pull in millions of views...and plenty of
comparisons to John Wick.
Hotel Artemis is about a hospital for assassins
that accepts the wrong patient, drawing in
the underworld's deadliest like moths to a
lamp.
Hotel Artemis is a no-vacancy, no-holds-barred
mashup of slick action and all-star faces.
Look for it in theaters on June 8th.
Incredibles 2
After 14 years of waiting, Incredibles 2 is
finally on the way.
Original writer/director Brad Bird is helming
the sequel, with most the of the original
voice cast back as well.
The timing couldn't be more perfect to rope
in all those fans of the first film, plus
their kids.
The new trailer sees Elastigirl heading out
to fight crime, leaving Mr. Incredible at
home to wrangle the kids.
In the latter half of the trailer, we get
glimpses of the whole family in action, along
with shots of the Underminer terrorizing the
city and the mysterious new villain The Screenslaver
brainwashing the citizens of Metroville.
Check out Incredibles 2 in theaters on June
15th.
Jurassic World: Fallen Kingdom
Universal Pictures released yet another teaser
for Jurassic World: Fallen Kingdom in April,
building the hype even higher for a movie
that millions of people are going to go see
anyway.
In the final full-length trailer, Universal
finally gets down to brass tacks, storywise.
Claire and Owen are heading back to the island
to rescue the dinosaurs from a volcano, but
the corporation that sends them isn't interested
in happy dinos, they want to use Owen's velociraptor,
Blue, to make a new hybrid weapon and auction
it off to the highest bidder.
Nobody's taking bets on whether anything goes
wrong with that plan.
Look for Jurassic World: Fallen Kingdom in
theaters on June 22nd.
The First Purge
You've seen three years of the Purge, now
get ready for the one that started it all.
There are some serious shenanigans at work
in the trailer for The First Purge, with the
government enlisting black ops soldiers to
help get the ball rolling on the first night
of their new experiment.
Turns out, people aren't so keen to go on
those bloody rampages after all.
"I can't run around chopping people's heads
off one day a year, and then sleep well the
rest of the time."
"Well you better start getting used to it,
little bitch, because we've got some f---ing
company."
Writer and director James DeMonaco, who helmed
the first three Purge films, returns as the
writer on The First Purge, with Gerard McMurray
stepping in as director.
The First Purge drops into theaters on July
4th.
The Equalizer 2
In this sequel to 2014's The Equalizer, Denzel
Washington returns as Robert McCall, the ultimate
man of peace who you definitely don't want
to mess with.
The trailer showcases Washington going on
a rampage while keeping plot details pretty
much under wraps, promising an adrenaline-fueled
ride packed with plenty of surprises.
Check it out when The Equalizer 2 turns up
the heat on July 20th.
Night School
In a summer filled to the brim with monster
films, superhero smackdowns, and spine-tingling
horror, Night School is bound to be a breath
of fresh air.
The comedy stars Kevin Hart as a successful
grill salesman whose life is flipped upside
down when his store blows up.
When nobody will hire him because he's a high-school
dropout, he suddenly finds himself at the
bottom of the corporate ladder, enrolling
in night school to get his G.E.D.
With a script co-written by Kevin Hart, Night
School co-stars Tiffany Haddish and enrolls
in a theater near you on September 28th.
The Meg
Throughout his career, Jason Statham has gone
up against gypsies, human traffickers, '80s
action stars, and his own heart.
Now, he's facing his biggest foe yet, a prehistoric
sea monster.
The Meg sees Statham starring as Jonas Taylor,
an ex-Navy Captain who's recruited to help
with a rescue mission on a deep-sea research
station.
The only problem is, there's a 70-foot predator
roaming the seas.
In the first trailer for The Meg, we get some
underwater action, some explosions, and at
least one too many jokes about how there's
no way this Megalodon's actually a Megalodon,
even though it's clearly a Megalodon.
"It's a Megalodon."
"He's kidding, right?"
Take the plunge when The Meg arrives on August
10th.
Venom
After teasing the world with a Venom trailer
that didn't feature any Venom, Sony finally
released a trailer chock-full of the symbiote.
The teaser introduces Tom Hardy's character,
Eddie Brock, a reporter digging into a story
involving a shadowy tech company called the
Life Foundation that's apparently been attempting
to merge people with symbiotes.
When Brock gets infected with a symbiote,
the Life Foundation's Dr. Carlton Drake sends
his henchmen after the guy, and they end up
getting more than they bargained for.
Another highlight of the new trailer is the
introduction of Venom's voice, also voiced
by Hardy.
Look for Venom to hit theaters on October
5th.
The Man Who Killed Don Quixote
It took almost 20 years for Terry Gilliam
to bring his passion project about Don Quixote
to fruition, and the long journey is finally,
almost, over.
The original incarnation starred Johnny Depp,
but a long, troubled production eventually
sucked the funding out of the movie, and everyone
went their separate ways.
After multiple restarts, misfires, and casting
replacements, the film now stars Adam Driver,
with Jonathan Pryce as Don Quixote.
And believe it or not, the Don Quixote curse
has struck again, as of April 2018, Gilliam
is still embroiled in a legal battle over
the new film's distribution rights.
Fingers crossed that all those troubles come
to an end and The Man Who Killed Don Quixote
finally reaches theaters.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!